hey what's up guys my PhD here and every
once in a while you got to switch it up
which is exactly what I'm doing with
headphones again trying a new pair every
once in a while and this is the most
recent pair I gave a shot these are the
AKG K 702 I promised I didn't pick him
up just because of red and black
although that definitely helped I picked
them up because they already kind of
have a great reputation
this whole k7 series already has all
great reviews and people seem to love
them you keep recommending them to me so
when they dropped on mass drop then yeah
I just totally picked them up and
they're quite nice so these run now
right around 250 bucks actually recently
a little less around 230 on Amazon so
they're not cheap and they're not shy
about being reference headphones which
is on the box and on the headphones
themselves and in the name so that's
what you got to analyze them as so for
all intents and purposes these are a
custom colorway of the AKG 702 s and
they are a very simple straightforward
pair of open back reference monitors so
what that means is in terms of features
there's not a whole lot of crazy stuff
going on here I know a lot of consumer
headphones like to mess around with you
know bass ports and dials and adjustable
sound these are just about as simple as
it gets just a clean no frills pair of
headphones the one thing you do have
gone for them though is comfort this is
one of the most comfortable pairs of
headphones I've ever worn you kind of
feel like you could wear them for hours
and not even notice you're still wearing
them which is exactly what you want with
reference monitor headphones because
you'll be wearing them for a long period
of time while you work the cups are big
and they go completely around your ear
and then the foam on the inside is this
super soft like almost sort of like a
memory foam so it holds its shape and
move slowly doesn't get sweaty like
leather it's nice and then they're super
lightweight I still do like a little bit
of padding on the top of most headphones
these aren't padded but it saves weight
and the mechanism for how adjustable
they are is super simple it's just
really flexible it slides freely
so no notches or anything and then the
headphones can fit all types of head
shapes from you know kids head to a huge
head whatever so you drop it on your
head and that thin leather band just
kind of holds it up there
and the headphones are light enough that
they're super comfortable like I said
also the earcup foam is so thick that
they prop the actual inside of the
headphone completely off your ears so
the inside of the ear cup is just kind
of this empty space that the sound seems
to come from it's more popular with
bigger headphones so with all this talk
about the comfort and no frills approach
you're probably wondering how do they
sound well actually that's kind of easy
they sound like reference headphones
they're very flat clean balanced and
just a little bit warm
the biggest difference you'll actually
notice with these and most other pairs
of headphones is that they are open back
so soundstage is way wide and the
different parts of the track sound like
they're coming from different parts of
the room around you I did an entire
video all about you know open-back
headphones and what those are like so
you can check that out these fall into
that category
and another thing since they're open you
all know what that means
sound leak these leak like a lot of
sound even more than normal which I
think you know isn't really a big deal
in most situations if you're using these
like in a studio or something but just
something to keep in mind if you were
planning on bringing these to work or
something so overall I was happy with
the sound now whether it came from a
preamp or my desktop or plugged straight
into a laptop it always gave me that
accurate representation of my audio they
might not be the most fun for music
listening because they are so flat I
mean even the master op Edition have
tuned it up the bass is bumped by three
decibels but even they still sound
pretty flat so can escape the design and
that's basically it
so to summarize what are you getting for
your money you're getting simple
headphones not a whole lot in the way
features but you do get some quality
materials you know some brushed metal
plastic up here some real leather over
here and a super comfortable overall
package thanks to some crafty
engineering and I'm thinking they're
pretty durable too so yeah they're maybe
not great for typical music listening
but they're awesome for monitoring
because that's what they're made for and
at the end of the day they're pretty
easy to recommend and like I said
obviously there are some others that do
the same thing for the same price but
the main advantage of these I think is
their comfort so they're worth checking
out I'm glad I found them I'll link to
them below and I think they're also
$1.99 for a couple more days on mass
drop if you want to grab that quick
discount that's been it thank you for
watching and I'll talk to you guys in
the next one peace